Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan. Wir stehen wieder vor dem Salon.
Wir sitzen, ja.
Wir sitzen, ganz richtig. Da frage ich dich, hast du denn schon die Haftbefehl-Doku geguckt?
Hab ich nicht. Ich habe ja einen echten Musikgeschmack. Also ich lass mir das ja nicht von Juan Moreno erklären, was jetzt cool ist. Deswegen war ich am Wochenende bei André Rieu.
Ja.
Und gestern bei Nina Chuba. Und das ist im Grunde die Erzählung.
Ja, aber irgendwo dazwischen ist ja vielleicht auch Platz für Haftbefehl. Ich erinnere mich, und du wirst dich vielleicht auch erinnern, an die Föjeton Jahre 2014, 15, 16, als es im Föjeton absolut dazugehörte, dass man große Texte, Elogen auf Haftbefehl schrieb. Zum Beispiel auch in deiner FAZ.
Okay.
Ja, ja.
So war das damals. Ich weiß nicht, wer Haftbefehl ist. Ich weiß, er hat ein Lied, das heißt 069. Ich wohne hier in 069. Könnte aber auch Offenbach sein. Also soweit ist schon. Er ist dann auf dem Bach aufgewachsen. Okay. Für mich ist das alles so weit weg wie Eintracht Frankfurt. Also es gibt anscheinend zwei große Sachen, die, also ich weiß nicht mal, wie der aussieht. Ich weiß gar nichts. Aber ich möchte euch den Podcast Brennpunkt empfehlen. Da wird darüber geredet, wie man das auch sehen kann, dass irgendwelche Hamburg-Mitte-Journalisten, die sich ja mal verdient gemacht haben, mit denen sie oder Lothius aber jetzt selber ins Märchen-Business abgedriftet sind und uns einfach so ein migrantisches Schicksal zum Fraß vorwerfen, bei dem möglichst ausgeblendet wird. Das ist ja ein Netflix-Doku von etablierten deutschen Institutionen. Alle schauen die und reden dann nur über Haftbefehl. Also auch immer wieder wunderbar, wie man so ein Apparat einfach ausblenden kann.